the division has intercepted a message
between captain lewis and general
anderson the new leader of the true sons
five of them including major castillo
are moving in on dc
something big is coming
[Music]
[Music]
malcolm castillo was the senior engineer
at the pentko fairview nuclear power
plant
expecting his first child with his wife
sharon the prospect of the future was
both exciting and daunting
he'd always been very particular about
how things should be done and when it
came to preparing the house for the
arrival of their new baby this was of no
exception
castillo had a plan and this would be
one of the major contributions he could
actually do for his expectant wife and
he was eager to get started as soon as
possible
so for the sake of their marriage and to
avoid any more unnecessary stress sharon
had decided that at five months pregnant
it would be a good time to visit her
family in new york
this would also be one of the last times
she would be completely child free and a
black friday shopping spree with her
sister in manhattan sounded perfect
the plan was simple she was to spend two
weeks bonding with her sister while
castillo focused on getting the house
ready
unbeknownst to her and the multitude of
shoppers on black friday a deadly virus
known as the green poison had been
released
and sadly while out shopping sharon 2
contracted the virus
assuming that it was no more than just
the flu she refused to seek treatment
her main concern was that the doctors
might prescribe her something that could
harm her unborn baby
ten days later
at a clinic in brooklyn
sharon died
utterly broken and grieving the loss of
his wife and unborn child
castillo immersed himself deeply into
his work in the hopes of keeping his
mind busy eventually he moved himself
into the facility to ensure that the
plant remained functional at all times
as the pandemic continued to progress
the national guard was ultimately sent
in to protect the compound and in order
for castillo to remain on site he would
have to enlist
even after completing basic training his
primary objective still remained the
same
as the on-site expert he was to continue
in his role of keeping the power plants
safe and operational
however always there and in the back of
his mind he believed that sarah the jtf
the government and in turn the division
were all heavily responsible for what
happened to his family
he held the belief that there was no way
possible that they were unaware of
amherst's plans
and that they simply just allowed it to
happen
anderson who was a logistics officer to
the leader of the true sons antoine
ridgeway was successfully able to tap
into castillo's grief along with further
heightening his mistrust of the
government
by using castillo's anguish and genuine
experiences to express his deepest
heartbreak anderson was able to convince
the national guard to abandon their post
and thus allowing the true sons to take
control of the plant
nice to meet you castillo
i've heard great things wish i could say
the same dusk excuse me i don't care if
your watch is red your division and now
you're working with the black tusk i can
assure you
i'm a true son then why are you still
wearing that garbage the best way i can
support the true sons is to take
advantage of the existing infrastructure
i thought that was something we had in
common you're smart so are you
and we are specialists in our fields
as long as you are loyal to ridgeway
to the cause
i promise to keep you safe you really
are a true son i am
now give me the tour
i've never been to a power plant before
do i need to wear like a lead-lined suit
or something
only if you go near the reactor or your
radiation meter goes into the red
but
that won't happen
lynette edwards codenamed dusk was a
third generation marine
shortly after her first tour she was
recruited by the shd
after the outbreak dusk was activated in
washington dc but it didn't take long
for her to come to the conclusion that
the institution was corrupt
in fact she was finding herself more and
more aligned with the true son's way of
thinking
eventually she decided that enough was
enough she turned rogue and joined up
with the true sons
when the true sons leader antoine
ridgeway was eventually hunted down and
killed by the division dusk went on to
continue ridgway's work with a group of
true sons who were devoted to his cause
unfortunately the attacks had left them
weakened and short on supplies she would
do whatever it took to help her new
family
dusk would use her contacts to gain a
connection within the black tusk and
offer a trade in return for food water
and weapons
barton schaefer would get in contact she
explained the situation that her and the
true sons were in supplies were
critically low and that they didn't have
enough weapons to go around
baden agreed to the request of
assistance and made a deal where they
could work together
with all of this happening castillo
would keep on working tirelessly to keep
the power plant operational while also
continuing to obsess over the events
that led to his wife's death
castillo we've been having rolling
blackouts everything stable with the
grid nothing is stable with the grid
everything is old and failing that's
comforting should i be looking for a
fallout shelter everything is stable
with the reactor the reactor and the
grid are two separate things
trust me if the reactor failed you'd
know oh
well you're the expert your local power
supply has nothing to do with our work
here if you're having rolling blackouts
brownouts or unstable power you're gonna
need to send someone down to the relay
stations and transformers and see if
they need maintenance i'll see if i've
got anyone who knows that infrastructure
good luck
start with ex-public works employees
or i guess raid the secretary of the
interior's office for a map of the power
stations you're funny i'm serious
go to city hall they should have
schematics for all of this stuff
it should also be online your precious
isaac should have all that data
you should be an agent i'm happy being
an engineer i don't need to play sheriff
it's probably squatters someone taps
into the line doesn't know what they're
doing and [ __ ] up the whole system
you'll need to check the stations then
you need to send the exterminators to
take care of the rats chewing on the
wires should be like riding a bike for
you
agent
after some time had passed and the
leader of the true sons antoine ridgway
was killed by the division and then dusk
during the barden-schaefer manhunt
general anderson would step up and take
the reigns
anderson had ambitious goals for the
true sons and plan on expanding their
reach far beyond washington dc
it was around this time that castillo
had decided that it was time for him to
put down his work and investigate
further
he wanted to go into dc to find out more
and who was responsible
but without him on site there would be
no one to run the power plant
so anderson made a deal with him to
train up true sons members to work in
his place while he was gone
how are the new recruits doing great
we've got four shifts 10 people per
shift
40 skilled prisoners trained and ready
to operate the reactor in case anything
happens to me
each shift has a true sun at the helm to
keep them in line and train any future
replacements and each of them has two
backups
we're set for the worst case scenario
and the best case best case if we want
to expand our operations we have the
opportunity to build a mobile team to
take control over another reactor
the infrastructure design and basic
mechanics are similar enough that my
crew should be able to figure out how to
keep the lights on that's excellent news
castillo thank you sir
about that favor you've more than earned
it
transpose on their way you will have a
squadron at your disposal
good luck in dc
i hope you find what you're looking for
thank you sir
after training enough true sons to run
the plant general anderson rewarded his
dedication by sending him to washington
dc to investigate sarah and the
division's role in his wife's death
but anderson had ulterior motives behind
this gift
having already used castillo's speaking
talents to gain control of the power
plant without bloodshed previously
he saw a powerful propaganda machine
that could be placed in the middle of dc
there he could continue to bolster the
true sun's ranks or at the very least
provide a much needed distraction
it was a win either way in anderson's
eyes
there is no reason that amherst should
have been allowed to release his poison
on the world
other than some idiot with access made a
choice
and the choice they made was to let my
wife sharon castillo
and her sister carolyn owens and my
daughter
who we were waiting to meet to name
my child who i will never be able to
name because i will never be able to
meet her because she was still inside of
cheryl those monsters dumped their
bodies into a mass grave in central park
and set it on fire to contain the virus
my wife and daughter
paid the price for their negligence
after taking back a number of strategic
points of interest castillo and a group
of true sons would eventually be tracked
down and confronted by division agents
at the dcd headquarters
there he would face off against the
division agents
eventually being brought down
and killed
at the conclusion to the manhunt target
kelso summed up the situation
castillo was consumed by his grief he
was in pain and was directing his pain
onto others
but this wasn't all his fault
the true sons exploited his mental state
using him as a recruitment tool to bring
others to their cause
and once they were done with them they
had no problems casting them aside
castillo's story is a simple one but a
really nice one to start with
although very straightforward it opens
us up to a number of bits and pieces
that are happening behind the scenes and
something much larger that is playing
out including the new character calvin
mcmanus that has appeared in comms
talking with natalia sokolova
but i'll talk about this one soon in
another video
online yannick has said that they've
placed a new objective of connecting the
story with the current state of the
world
and being someone that's often trying to
make the story feel a little more
real i'm stoked to see this
my concerns about the story being told
in a more direct manner have been
alleviated i was worried that the more
direct way of bringing the story to the
player would potentially remove some of
the depth but fortunately i was wrong in
fact i would say that the story is
showing more depth and a hell of a lot
more emotion that we've received in
previous manhunts i found myself far
more engaged with castillo's story
as i said though this is just the start
after a long break i suspect things will
get very interesting soon
thank you very much for watching and
especially big thank you to all of the
new paid ngn members who've joined the
channel recently it seriously means a
lot to me and the family
anyway i'll catch you in the next one
cheers
[Music]
we found the records
we found the proof
they deemed him
not a credible threat right
all of this blood is on their hands
they allowed this to happen
do not let them get away with this
the true sons are fighting for your
freedom from their tyranny
do not believe the government's lies
the green poison
is just the beginning